Speaker 1: Hey, David, what with Republican anti
Voxer ism, when will covid become a Republican
virus? This is we've talked about this a little
bit increasingly. Covid is already becoming a
more and more Republican virus. And in the United
States, what do we know? We know that last month,
for example, ninety nine percent of those who
died of the coronavirus were unvaccinated, not 100
percent, but ninety nine percent. When you look at
the 20 percent of the country that doesn't want to
get vaccinated, it's overwhelmingly Republicans.
Somewhere between 43 and 50 percent of Republicans
don't want to get vaccinated, whereas most
independents do and almost every Democrat
wants to get or has gotten vaccinated. So you've
got this big gap in vaccination by political
affiliation, by party. And overwhelmingly,
the people that are dying of the virus now
are people that are unvaccinated. So I believe
that it already is to some degree and very soon
will be even more of a Republican virus. Now, the
question that some people have been writing in
with is a slightly different question, which is,
is it possible that by virtue of Republicans not
getting vaccinated and the virus over time killing
more Republicans, that it will actually have an
electoral impact because more Republicans than
Democrats will die and therefore Democrats will
win more elections? Probably not. Probably not.
There's a couple of different things here. First
of all, when you look at the number of votes, you
know, Joe Biden got 80 million, Donald Trump got
74 million. That's one hundred and fifty four
million votes right there. Covid has tragically
killed more than 600000 people. Fortunately, that
number is low relative to the voting population
that I mean, maybe there's some local races where
if it's a really red county and it's really like
almost all Republicans who die from covid over the
next year, whatever, up until the twenty election,
maybe there's like a local race where it
could make a difference. But big picture,
I don't expect that that is actually going to
make an electoral difference. The other thing
that you have to remember is a Republican. One of
the things that we we know from early in the virus
that contributes to spread in people
getting sick is population density.
And because Democrats, more than Republicans
like to live in cities and because cities and
urban areas tend to be more Democratic, that's
a structural disadvantage when it comes to
virus deaths for Democrats relative to
Republicans. So I think increasingly this
is going to be a Republican virus. I don't think
it's going to have electoral consequences. But if
you disagree with my very rough kind of back of
the envelope math on it, certainly let me know.